On humans and other primates, nails are a
flattened version of a claw which likely developed
to aid in gripping and climbing.
However, they can also act as a visible “health
report.”
Someone in poor health, or infected by a fungus,
might have yellow, brittle nails, while someone
in good health might have strong, long nails.
The fact that healthy nails are the sign of
a healthy person may have led to people beginning
to grow them out, or it could have been simply
that long nails are cumbersome when working
with your hands, so they were something of
a status symbol.
Whatever the case, it might surprise you to
learn that manicuring nails has actually been
around for many thousands of years—dating
back at least to 3200 B.C.
At the time, Chinese royalty would grow their
nails and tint them with things like eggwhites
or flower petals.
Around the same time, Ancient Egyptians were
also painting their nails, this time in accordance
with their social classes; richer Egyptians
painted their nails a darker colour, while
poorer Egyptians painted them a lighter colour.
The modern practice of growing out and painting
nails is a result of a more recent occurrence,
happening in the 1920s and 1930s where women
began growing long, luxurious nails.
Before this, women commonly tinted their nails
with oil or glosses.
However, in the 1920s, shortly after the introduction
and popularity of automobile paint, proper
nail paint also became available and a nail
painting boom resulted.
Of course, many “proper” women didn’t
dare paint their nails for several decades
after that, but Hollywood stepped in.
In 1940, it became the style to have long,
red nails, likely spurred on by actress Rita
Hayworth.
Many women started copying her style, striving
to look like the knockout celebrity.
Much like painting one’s nails, artificial
nails, which mimic real nails and add length
and a healthy appearance to nails, have an
astoundingly long history.
Artificial nails were once worn by Chinese
women during the Ming Dynasty (14th -17th
century).
In this case, these nail extensions were worn
by noblewomen to further show that they did
not have to use their hands for manual labour,
unlike commoners.
There are also records of women in 19th century
Greece using pistachio shells as artificial
nails.
It wasn’t until 1954 that an early version
of the modern artificial nail was invented.
It was first patented by Fred Slack, a dentist,
who had chipped his nail at work and needed
a replacement.
He and his brother worked with various materials
before coming up with something that would
work, starting with dental acrylic, resulting
in a realistic-looking fake nail that soon
became incredibly popular among women across
the world.
Since then Slack’s company, Nail Systems
International, has continued to innovate creating
fake nails out of a variety of substances.
Of course, as with everything beauty and style
related, growing nails out and painting them
are trends that come and go.
During the 1960s, women preferred a more natural
look and rarely painted their nails.
Nail painting saw a huge come-back in the
1980s, though, and since then the practice
has been relatively popular in certain countries
in
the world.